- Pros and cons of standing desks.
Pro, improves ability to talk about
having a standing desk, facts.
The Onion is a satirical news source,
satirical, it's a joke.
It pokes fun at us humans.
We need to laugh and smile more
and not take The Onion seriously,
'cause I've seen some people
tweet out Onion headlines,
shocked as if they were true articles.
- [Man] Dr. Anthony Fauci,
director of the National
Institute of Allergy
and Infectious Diseases.
But a disturbing report today has revealed
that the now infamous immunologist
may actually just be a figment
of the nation's collective imagination.
Hear more about how millions of Americans
are all having the same
exact hallucinations
of the so-called Dr. Fauci.
- Honestly, Dr. Fauci, is that good.
That he could totally be a hallucination.
Do you know why?
No, he's not hallucination
because I actually interviewed.
- [Dr. Fauci] Dr. Mike, how are you?
- First of all, let me
say a huge thank you
for joining us on the YouTube channel.
Everyone in the news keeps saying.
Doctor informs woman she pregnant as hell.
I don't even think this is a real doctor.
What is happening here?
What is this false identification
little loose-leaf paper
he has here with no name?
And that's a disposable stethoscope folks.
Why is he wearing it?
Why is there no name tag?
Why does he have a laser pointer?
This is not a person you should trust.
Pros and cons of standing desks.
Pro, improves ability to talk about
having a standing desk.
Facts, two most common
conversations I have with patients.
Those who are vegan,
about them being vegan
and those who have a standup desk
and wanna tell me about
their standup desk.
Encourage more natural spinal curvature
while staring at screen
for eight continuous hours.
Increase blood flow to your feet
where your best thinking
is done, that's funny.
One step closer toward the
ultimate dream of flying desks.
Con, could wind up forgetting
how to sit entirely.
Eliminates satisfaction of
leaning back in your chair
with your hands behind your head
after sending a killer email.
Ooh, that feels good.
You'll still eventually die.
Doctors warn Marshawn Lynch
that the next time he goes into beast mode
could kill him.
I'm on beast mode right now
for this YouTube channel.
I see this misinformation
and I'm just going beast, me and Marshawn.
Cubs team doctor recommends Anthony Rizzo
rehab injured ankle by engaging
in light physical
activities like baseball.
Professional athletes to
a professional athletes.
But baseball is the definition
of a sedentary activity.
Running around the bases
should be totally fine
and is actually great
way to rebuild strength.
There is actually really good exercises
that you can do to rehab an
ankle that are not baseball.
And a lot of them are about
regaining your range of motion.
And then it's about
regaining your stability.
That ligament that is most often injured
is called the anterior
talofibular ligament.
And because of that,
when you step forward,
you can lose some of that stability
and you could fall forward.
Beyonce begins painful
surgical transformation
to prepare for her role in
live action "Lion King" remake.
Once the radical alterations
to her bones and musculature
and skin are completed, you
won't even be able to tell
that the big old cat
you're looking on screen
is actually Beyonce.
The process would begin with
breaking and readjusting
the pop star's spinal
column, and pelvic bones
to allow her to comfortably
walk quadrupedally.
Never said that word publicly before.
There's commitment to acting
and then there's becoming a real lion
And somewhere there needs
to be a medical line
that should not be crossed.
Sick man slowly becoming
enthroned in used tissues.
Must be soft and comfy, but kind of gross
'cause it's mucusy at the same time.
Local woman considers telling
gynecologist whole truth.
Local woman, Denise Bowers,
was mentally calculating
the precise amount of information
she would have to divulge
in order to obtain powerful
prescription antibiotics.
Patients wanna divulge as
least amount of information
to get what they think is
the accurate treatment.
That is why whenever a
patient comes into my office,
in addition to asking them
questions about their symptoms,
their history, and doing a physical exam,
I also ask them at the end of every visit,
what is their theory?
What did they think is going on?
'cause if they leave my office unsatisfied
or without truly getting an answer
to the question that's deep in here,
I'm not doing my job as a doctor.
- I'm Perry Bigwell and
today Rob Gronkowski.
After missing most of the
2013 season with injuries,
the loose assemblage of
screws, splintered bones,
and mangled joints that make
up the Patriots tight end
- This image.
- [Perry] For a massive comeback.
There are a lot of
questions surrounding Gronk
this fantasy football season
but I say ride that creature to the end.
- I feel like Rob Gronkowski
is truly a bionic man
at this point.
Not because his surgeries
and fixes that he's had,
but he just doesn't go down.
I remember in the "Entourage" movie,
he's like partying with a crutch
and he has like an injured
arm, like a broken arm
and he's like still partying.
I've had my shoulder like gets sore,
like I don't wanna get out of bed.
Robert Gronkowski, he's like,
"Let's go take some hits."
Study finds healthy lifestyle
can cut risk of developing
Alzheimer's by 60%.
I'm getting sick of researchers
expecting me to do things
when they should be the
ones coming up with cures.
People must really hate Alzheimer's
if they're willing to live a
healthy long life to avoid it.
So you're saying nothing I can do?
In order for us to find
cures we need to figure out
what we can do first and then
figure out the mechanism,
thereby reducing that risk,
thereby being able to implement
the cure or treatment, you dig?
Latest study finds cancer cells
now cruelly mocking researchers.
A new Mayo Clinic study
with widespread implications
for the treatment or
potential cure of the disease
has found that the malignant growths
are basically flipping off
scientists left and right
and get a huge kick out
of making oncologists
feel like a bunch of bumbling chumps.
I would love if when
oncologists or pathologists
are looking under the microscope
to see if the treatments are working
and the malignant cells are
just sitting there like,
"You can't catch me, you can't catch me."
Real headline.
Doctors edit living
patient's DNA for first time.
I'm just worried about
the moral considerations
of helping sick people with Greg Paulson.
Is a window defroster a career?
It will be a great day when all doctors
can defy God's plan like this.
I feel like that's a Drake lyric.
The field of injecting
things never stops advancing.
That's true, we like
injecssing stuff, injecssing.
True headline.
FDA set to approve
gene-altering cancer treatment.
The FDA is expected to approve
a new leukemia treatment
that alters the patient's
cells to target cancer cells
with hope it gets someday fight
other types of cancer too.
What do you think?
I would only alter my genes
to become more powerful
not less sick.
So you pay for some fancy treatment,
but it's your body doing the actual work?
What is scam.
All of medicine is your body
doing the work, literally,
unless I'm actively doing
a surgical procedure
to fix something and put it together,
it's their body doing the work.
In fact, when the surgeon connects things,
we don't even connect it all the way.
We usually just like kinda line it up
and let the body heal itself anyway.
Insurance only covers
generic heart transplant.
My doctor says it should
work exactly the same
as any other heart, it has the same valve,
same ventricle, same everything.
Aside from lacking any branding,
the heart he's receiving
is essentially identical
to the more expensive ones.
Frankly, as long as it keeps on beating,
I don't care where it's from.
This is a play on generic medications.
Yes, generic medications are
the same as the branded ones.
When you go in to buy
aspirin and you're like,
"Can I get Bayer?"
You're still paying for aspirin.
When you say Bayer, that's
a company, that's a brand
but you don't have to buy
the brand to get the aspirin.
Same thing with a set of acetaminophen,
Tylenol is the brand name of that.
Dr. Dilshad Atwal and I
who's an interventional
pain medicine doctor
looked at memes together.
He struggled, it's worth a
watch, check it out here.
And if you didn't see the previous episode
of my Onion medical reviews,
click here for that episode as well.
And as always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)